There's lots of things about the world under
Donald Trump that make me despair for humanity
or that make me worried or that shock me or
surprise me or whatever else.
But one of the things that I really just straight
up resent about the Trump administration is
that it's forcing us to have to reexplain
and a lot of really simple concepts that I
previously thought we sort of had a pretty
firm grasp on that have apparently been thrown
out the window under Donald Trump.
So for example, tariffs, I talked yesterday
about tariffs extensively.
China and Mexico don't pay for Donald Trump's
tariffs.
The American companies and the American people
who import the stuff from China and Mexico
are the ones actually paying for the tariffs.
Voter fraud.
We just talked about it in the first segment
today.
Doesn't matter what Trump and his followers
say in person voter fraud to the t to the
tune of these three to 5 million illegal votes,
Donald Trump claims took place in 2016 it
doesn't exist.
Okay, well we've talked about it all.
Brennan Center for Justice Study.
Uh, we, we know it's just, it's just not real
and we're having to reexplain this under Donald
Trump.
I could go on and give you a long list, but
I want to focus in on one specific one today,
which is that under Trump, since Trump's tax
reform plan was put in place, all of a sudden
people are pretending that his tax cut would
go to the middle class and that the part that
goes to the rich is also good because it gives,
uh, the economy more juice, so to speak.
There's this idea that giving tax cuts to
the rich stimulates the economy.
It trickles down.
All of that stuff.
We've already dealt with this.
Okay.
I've been dealing with it for years.
We've been dealing with it on the program.
Most recently we dealt with it under George
W. Bush.
Tax Cuts for the rich aren't particularly
stimulative to the economy and Republican
tax plans mostly give disproportionate amounts
of money to the rich and to big corporations
no matter what they tell you.
And once again, that's what happened with
the Trump republican tax reform that was passed
during Donald Trump's first term.
There's a really great report from the Congressional
Research Service called the economic effects
of the 2017 tax revision.
Preliminary observations.
You might remember we were told it would be
great for all Americans.
We were told it would let makers keep their
money.
It would incentivize businesses to invest
more in their businesses and in their employees,
which would cause wages to rise.
It would stimulate economic growth.
We were told that even though in the short
term it would reduce the amount of money that
the government takes in that it would very
quickly pay for itself because of all the
growth and winning and all of this that would
be created and ultimately the government would
actually be taking in more money.
None of it has happened.
Wages have continued to increase slowly, but
they're increasing at the same rate that they
were increasing before the tax reform plan
went into effect.
Growth has continued on the same trend line
as before, the tax reform plan, but what did
happen as a result of Trump's tax plan is
lower the effective tax rate for the super
rich by a significant percentage and hugely
in terms of the raw dollars.
That went back to the very rich relative to
the middle class and the lower middle class
and the poor.
So Trump personally and his friends made out
really, really well from this tax plan.
What it did do was cause businesses to use
the money not to reinvest in their own businesses
or employees, but to start repurchasing shares
of their own stock to drive up the price,
which again is a way of using the money from
the tax cuts to mostly help they're big shareholders
and their executives.
It's almost like we knew this would happen
when they first started talking about this
type of tax reform because this is how it
happens every single time.
And I want to be really clear, this is not
me speaking out against the tax plan because
I'm jealous that the tax plan was bad for
me and good for other people.
This tax reform was very good for me.
Okay.
I did a whole segment several months ago when
I had filed my taxes, explaining how, even
though the David Pakman show grew from 2017
to 2018 my effective tax rate as the majority
owner of the David Pakman show went down from
26% effective federal tax rate for the 2017
tax year, 26% down to under 22% in 2018 I'll
take the money.
Okay.
But my point in talking about that in talking
about it again here is that it is not economically
stimulative in terms of policy to do the type
of tax reform.
That saves me like 15% on taxes.
Four out of 26 is roughly about 15% and disproportionately
more going to the very, very rich and corporations
who are saving the money, who are using the
money to repurchase a, to do stock buy backs,
etc.
Last thing, we call these the Trump tax cuts,
but really they're republican tax cuts.
So if you're not happy with the tax reform
plan, yes, Trump is to blame and yes, Trump
should be voted out.
In 2020 he supported the tax plan.
He worked on the tax plan with Republicans,
but it's the Republicans who wrote it and
actually pushed it through in the House and
Senate who are also responsible and they should
also be voted out in 2020 really important
not to forget that and blame this all on Trump
because it is much, much bigger than Donald
Trump.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show.
I've got a nice announcement coming up later
on the show today.
Hope you'll stay with them.